[Musik]
[Applaus]
Karl Lauterbach waren vor dem Drohnen
corona-wetter polenbau zwei neuer
turmkraftwerke und immer mehr Menschen
in Deutschland haben das Gefühl diese
Regierung die ganz einfach nicht und
damit herzlich willkommen bei Philipp 8
meine Gäste heute abend Uwe dohrendorf
CDU-Politiker und parteirebell er ärgert
sich über immer mehr verboten in unserem
Land NZZ Journalistin susanne Gaschke
sie sieht das Vertrauen in der Regierung
schwinden doch was könnte die
Alternative zur Ampelkoalition sein das
werde ich Sie fragen Informatiker Tom
Lausen er rechnet Gesundheitsminister
Karl Lauterbach heute Abend hier vor das
seine corona-politik vorne und hinten
nicht passt und fordert ein Ende der
Impfpflicht im Gesundheits- und
Pflegebereich da wird der Berliner
Internist Dr Peter Welling definitiv
nicht zustimmen wenn ich das mal so
Voraussagen darf denn er schwört weiter
aufs impfen schön dass Sie alle da sind
mein Name ist Lena Brockhaus ich freue
mich heute Abend ihre Gastgeberin sein
zu dürfen lassen Sie uns doch heute mit
einer kleinen Bibelstunde beginnen
und mit einem Zitat aus der Bibel es ist
in keinem anderen heil denn in dem Namen
Jesu zur Ehre Gottes des Vaters das in
dem Namen Jesu sich beugen sollen aller
derer Knie die im Himmel und auf Erden
und unter der Erde sind er diesen Satz
diesen Text an der Kuppel des nachgebaut
Berliner Stadtschlosses möchte die
Grünen Politikerin Claudia Roth nun
vorübergehend überblenden der Grund die
Kulturbeauftragte der Bundesregierung
hält den Bibeltext für nicht weltoffen
und unangemessen ich als Gläubige
Evangelien muss sagen dass ich das sehr
schwierig finde auch für mich persönlich
diese Einstellung zur Kirche Herr
dohrendorf überspitzt formuliert ist
denn der christliche Glaube unangemessen
natürlich nicht also gerade hier in
Deutschland ist er ja geprägt durch die
christlichen Glauben wir sind ja auch
sehr tolerant wir wissen ja dass wir in
einigen Moscheen und auch in Köln ja
sehr tolerant sind können
Medizin genau also man kann uns nicht
Vorwürfen dass das wir nicht tolerant
sind aber wir müssen es auch zu unserer
eigenen Kirche und zwar unserem eigenen
Land natürlich
bekunden und das halt wichtig und
insofern kann ich das überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen was Frau Rother gerade
macht aber das wieder typisch zu den
Grünen aber da kommen wir nachher noch
mal drauf ist sie denn für Sie generell
eine gute nein Frau nein also sie ist ja
sehr
schrill um das mal so auszudrücken
Schritt bin ich auch das können wir
nicht als Beleidigung gelten lassen nein
ich soll ja keine Beleidigung sein aber
das hat der Unterschied und alles in dem
Bereich was die da bringt ist halt nicht
mein Thema muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen
und es ist halt einfach schwierig ja man
ist tolerant aber so wie sie es jetzt
auch gerade macht dass man es abhängen
soll das ist unglaublich Frau Gaschke
also es ist ja schon merkwürdig dass das
jetzt überblendet werden soll aber wie
Herr dohrendorf auch gerade angesprochen
hat in Köln der Munition Ruf wie sehen
Sie denn die Entwicklung von Frau Roth
ich finde das auch unsinnig also nun hat
man sich das war ja sehr umstritten und
hat man sich entschlossen das
Stadtschloss historisierend wieder auf
es gab viele Leute die das lieber anders
gemacht hätten also was weiß ich eine
eingekapselt eingekapselten Palast der
Republik oder irgendwas wäre auch eine
interessante Variante gewesen hat man
also das historische genommen und die
historische Inschrift die dahin gehört
die darf da jetzt nicht stehen das passt
für mich in so einem großen Zusammenhang
es wird ja in vielen Städten gemacht
also bis hin dazu dass man die
erich-kästner-straße umbenennen will das
Hindenburgufer in meiner Heimatstadt
Kiel darf nur noch Kiellinie heißen und
ich glaube viele Linke haben immer die
Hoffnung dass die Geschichte dadurch
irgendwie besser wird dass man Sachen
umbenennt oder zudeckt und das ist
natürlich Unsinn die Geschichte bleibt
ganz genauso ich würde sagen es gibt
Fälle wo definitiv Erläuterungen nötig
sind das kann man ja immer machen gerade
in die Tafel dazu machen wobei man jetzt
die Frage also ob man einen Bibelzitat
jetzt erläutern muss es ist ja durchaus
menschenfreundlich also es ist ja nichts
Böses sozusagen insofern hier kann ich
es jetzt eigentlich gar nicht verstehen
und sie möchte es ja vorübergehend
während einer Ausstellung also in der
Kunstausstellung auch verblenden da habe
ich mich halt auch gefragt ob wir nicht
als weltoffen gelten als Deutschland
wegen Liebe Zitat das ist ja schon eine
merkwürdige Denkweise kann man sagen
dass generell die Grünen etwas gegen die
Kirche haben das glaube ich eigentlich
nicht wenn sie sich mal die evangelische
Synode ansehen oder so da ist durchaus
grün geprägt also sowohl vom Auftreten
als auch von den Themen her also da gibt
es durchaus eine Affinität und sozusagen
dieses grüne hat ja häufig auch etwas
protestantisch freudloses also
etwas anstrengende Weise also ich bin
Protestantin und sehr freudig immer
unterwegs aber das gibt es das gibt es
auch aber es gibt eben auch dieses Etwas
kabinistische oder also ja also insofern
ich ich kann es nicht ganz verstehen ich
glaube dass das Spannungsverhältnis wäre
doch viel ich weiß jetzt gar nicht in
welcher Ausstellung es geht aber wenn es
da ein Spannungsverhältnis geben sollte
ist doch viel interessanter das
auszuhalten und zu diskutieren
ich verstehe ganz viele Dinge nicht ich
bin ja datenanalyst und bei mir sind
immer sehr viele Grundlagen um eine
Abwägung zu machen um Abwägungsprozess
überhaupt einzuleiten ich kann den hier
gar nicht erkennen ich kann einfach nur
sehen dass hier aus einer bestimmten
Weltsicht heraus bestimmte Dinge gemacht
worden sind die werden einfach
durchgeführt und es wird nicht mit
irgendwem besprochen in einer großen in
einem großen Umfeld es wird einfach
gemacht und meines Erachtens haben wir
uns tatsächlich die neue Regierung
gewählt als eine Regierung der
kindlichen Weltsicht wir sehen das ja an
vielen verschiedenen Aspekten ich finde
dieser ist eigentlich ein gutes Beispiel
man macht sich die Welt wie man sie
gerne hätte und wie sie einem gefällt
und so findet das auch hier statt
kindische weltsichtung kindliche Welt
sich was verstehen Sie darunter darunter
verstehe ich Dinge die einfach so in den
Raum gerufen werden ohne eine fundierte
Grundlage zu haben und ohne zu wissen wo
das alles endet einfach mal etwas
umzukrempeln so macht man das ja auch in
der Sandkiste haben Sie das Gefühl dass
wir unsere Kultur auch ein Stück weit
aufgeben
wieder wegschieben wollen also insgesamt
ist ja die Frage jede jedes
zusammenlebende menschengeflecht ist ja
zunächst einmal grundsätzlich auf einem
Gebiet in dem es eine eigene Sprache
spricht und solange es eine eigene
Sprache spricht gibt es auch immer
Abgrenzungen zu anderen
menschengeflechten die eine andere
Sprache sprechen so das heißt also in
diesem Raum finden eigenständige Dinge
statt und diese eigenständigen Dinge
werden jetzt quasi
geändert und man experimentiert auf eine
gewisse Art und Weise ob die Änderungen
auch funktionieren oder nicht das weiß
man nicht und man hat auch gar keine
Prognosen dafür sondern man sagt einfach
man möchte das gerne und das ist für
mich eine Art von kindlicher
weltgestaltung und ob das gut ist oder
nicht wir haben das gewählt
offensichtlich ist in Deutschland ein
gewisser Spaß daran ein gewisses
Vergnügen daran die kindliche Weltsicht
von einer kindlichen Welt sich regiert
zu werden
sie sind kein Politikwissenschaftler
kein Religionswissenschaftler aber
trotzdem die Frage an Sie auch geben wir
ein Stück unserer Kultur auf wie
empfinden Sie das als Bürger
sehr eindeutig ich finde das Religion
nicht in die Öffentlichkeit gehört
sondern etwas sehr privates ist und sich
darüber aufzuregen wir haben genug
Glaubenskriege im Leben geführt fände
ich einfach viel besser wenn man das aus
diesem ganzen Diskussionen raushält und
vor allen Dingen dabei kann
missionarischen Eifer entwickelt sie
verstehen die Frau Roth dass sie das
überblenden möchte das Bibel versteht
als in ihrer Aufgabe eine Meinung haben
sollte ja ob das dann richtig ist oder
falsch ist sie noch immer unsere Sache
darüber nachzudenken aber eine zeitweise
Verblendung ändert ja nicht unsere
Kultur deswegen ich finde es einfach man
sollte überlegen was möchte sie damit
erreichen warum macht sie das es gibt ja
bestimmte Begründungen für viele Sachen
und da kann man sich ja anschließen und
nicht anschließen aber muss es ja nicht
mit in irgendwelchen Konfrontation
schwarz-weiß machen man kann es ja auch
wirklich mal versuchen zu verstehen
warum sie vielleicht Aussicht in Ansicht
ist und ich würde gerade beim Kreieren
sagen das ist eine Privatangelegenheit
und sollte auch so behandelt werden wenn
es um öffentliche Themen geht
ich können ja gerne eine andere Meinung
haben ja klar es ist ja ein bisschen
schwierig also Religion nicht in der
Öffentlichkeit also wir haben ja auch
überall Kirchen rumstehen die sozusagen
mit mit Kreuz auf dem Turm Bayern sind
kreuzen Glocken einfach sozusagen ja den
den christlichen Glauben sozusagen als
Gebäude darstellen schön dass die
christlichen Glauben gesagt haben nicht
evangelischen katholisch wie vorher weil
wir haben nur einen Himmel und wir haben
auch nur einen Glauben im Prinzip dass
uns zwischendurch da getrennt haben
finde ich immer noch schade weil der
christliche Glauben hat den gleichen
Ursprung und wir haben gibt aber schon
Unterschiede also ich bin wirklich
Gläubiger Evangelien und ich muss sagen
es gibt schon Unterschiede zwischen
katholisch und evangelisch ich war ganz
große Unterschiede ich bin Kölsch
katholisch was besondere Form ist und
ich habe lange eine ökumenischen
Beziehung gelebt deswegen ich kenne
beide Kirchen und auch von ihren
Vorständen und so weiter her deswegen ja
das wäre schöner wenn wir zusammen wären
vielleicht einfach Fall also was was ich
tatsächlich bei Frau Roth eben nicht gut
verstehen kann ist also nun leben wir ja
mal damit dass also der Bundestag in
seiner Weisheit beschlossen hat also das
war ein Bund Länder Entscheidung wenn
ich mir recht erinnere sozusagen dieses
Schloss in dieser Form wieder aufzubauen
das kann man aus vielen Gründen ja auch
ziemlich merkwürdig finden also soll man
überhaupt historische Gebäude dann
wieder so nachbauen oder ist das im
Grunde so eine Disneyland Veranstaltung
dann also hätte man diesen Platz da
nicht auch anders gestalten können hätte
man sich mit der DDR Geschichte nicht
tatsächlich irgendwie auseinandersetzen
können jetzt mal abgesehen vom Asbest im
Palast der Republik wenn man das aber
tut dann sozusagen ein Teil der
historischen Wahrheit nämlich dass man
sich zu der Zeit auf diese Art von
Christentum berufen hat und das eben
öffentlich einfach auszulassen oder
abzuhängen das verstehe ich
intellektuell tatsächlich nicht so
richtig was das soll wie wir klären sie
sich das denn ich erkläre das nicht ich
kann es nur wahrnehmen dass es nicht das
Christentum gibt sondern verschiedene
Glaubensrichtungen dabei und das ist da
auch verschiedene Meinungen
das schon ja auch in Köln ja aber es ist
ein Museen und wie warm wie viele
Kirchen ja also ich finde dass wir die
Multikulti-Gesellschaft durchaus auch
abbilden können und jedem der zu uns
gekommen ist und bei uns lebt auch sein
Zuhause geben kann ja und sich zu Hause
zu fühlen wir müssen doch nicht
konfrontativ damit umgehen dass es
direkt dicke bitte in Köln am lautesten
läutet ist ja immer noch so ich versuche
das zu verstehen also Bibelvers nein bzw
Überblendungen Ordnung Verblendung in
Ordnung aber muizin ruft ja das heißt
sie sind für religiöse Symbole oder
Tätigkeit in der Öffentlichkeit aber
nicht für alle
ich bin für religiöse Symbole in der
Öffentlichkeit wenn es die Religion
betrifft und den Menschen persönlich ja
aber ich bin eigentlich gegen
konfrontatives auseinandersetzen gerade
eine Meinung durchzusetzen wir haben ja
doch gelernt mittlerweile friedlicher
zusammenzuleben und müssen uns dann noch
nicht gegenseitig zankt über irgendwas
was wirklich keine weh tut man kann den
Spruch von unten überhaupt nicht lesen
man muss ihn schon abgebildet sehen um
überhaupt zu sehen was da oben steht er
denn dann Frau Roth genau das ist ja
wenn sie sagen ja genau aber ich meine
warum sollte er dann die Menschen
okay ja aber da können ja durchaus
verschiedene Meinungen sein absolut
dafür treffen wir uns hier ja immer
dienstags
wie hat sie denn das verhüllt wie sieht
denn das überhaupt
auseinander
es ist noch nicht verhüllt worden sie
will es verhüllen mit einem Tuch oder
mit etwas drüber es ist ja noch nicht
verhüllt das ist ja auch gerade erst
wieder aufgebaut der Stadtschloss okay
und dementsprechend werden wir jetzt mal
gucken so wie es in der Zukunft
weitergeht damit immer ein spannendes
Thema die Religionen und darüber zu
diskutieren aber Herr Dorendorf hat
heute auch ein spannendes Thema
mitgebracht was sie im Moment sehr
beschäftigen das ist nicht Frau Roth und
nicht die Religion nein das ist halt die
verteilte Grünen die ja sollte das
anders sein die für mich als
verbotspartei einfach sieht also am
liebsten möchten Sie dass wir kein Auto
mehr fahren das kann man hier in der
Stadt gerne wollen das kann man auch
machen ich komme aus der Fläche aus dem
schönen Landkreis Lüge Nürnberg und
Lüneburg da geht es eben nicht der
zweite Punkt ist ich soll kein Fleisch
mehr essen das ist ja so immer am besten
und am besten auch die Jagd sollte man
eigentlich verbieten bzw die Waffen dann
auch zentral lagern und das sind alles
so Punkte das finde ich halt einfach
schade und da ziehe ich natürlich nicht
mit ich sage diesen Veggie day den wir
ja mal hatten jeder Politiker der also
ein Ventile erfordert für den da freue
ich mich auf ein schönes Stück Fleisch
dass ich auf den Grill lege
provozierend sagt und ich finde einfach
es geht einfach zu weit auch bei der
Jagd wir haben 44 Rudel den in
Niedersachsen und fünf einzelne Wölfe
was die anrichten aber die Grüne sind
nicht bereit dort in dem Bereich
wirklich sich ein bisschen zu öffnen und
wenn man sieht was das für die Fläche
heißt in der Stadt ist das alles
wunderbar aber wenn Sie mit dem Hund in
der Fläche spazieren gehen und Sie
wissen nicht kommen jetzt ein Rudel
entgegen was passiert jetzt eigentlich
oder wenn sie sehen wir haben sehr viele
Reiterhöfe die dann nach ihrem springen
und nach Frisuren einfach im Wald
ausreiten wenn die den Wolf mitbekommen
die Pferde dann gehen die einfach durch
ist und einfach überall wieder gefahren
und wir müssen einfach in dem Bereich
offener sein und das ist bei den Grünen
nicht so der Fall kann sich heute auch
extra jagdlich angezogen und mein
modisches Statement zu setzen nein nicht
unbedingt ich trage sowieso ja jagdliche
Kleidung auch als jagdpolitischer
Sprecher der CDU und in der Fraktion in
Niedersachsen aber ich fühle mich auch
in dieser Kleidung wohl und nach außen
zeige ich das natürlich auch weil man
natürlich auch mal gerne Gegner
miteinander wir wollen ja reden man kann
ja nur Menschen überzeugen indem man
halt und für mich ist das Bio also das
Wildfleisch für mich das beste Bio
Fleisch was es gibt insofern bin ich
auch Verfechter und nicht nur Fleisch
ist sondern auch von diesem köstlichen
Fleisch und insofern großartiges Rehwild
ja
noch haben wir es noch haben wir es der
Wolf hat bei uns völlig die das
Muffelwild schon dezimiert das gibt's
nicht mehr jetzt geht es gerade ans
Damwild und wenn das nicht reicht weil
das sind so Fluchttiere die nicht ganz
so schnell sind dann geht es an die
Schafe an die polnisch an die Rinde
wir wollen ihn ja nicht ausrotten und
wir haben 44 Rudel das ist eine ganze
Menge nur für Niedersachsen da kommt
Brandenburg Sachsen-Anhalt noch dazu
nein ich möchte den regulieren dass wir
eine Untergrenze wie in Frankreich haben
und alles was da drüber ist ob das nun
80 oder 100 Würfe sind die müssen dann
geschossen werden so einfach ist das wie
bei jedem anderen Bild auch Frau Gaschke
neben der Jagd kommen wir zum
eigentlichen Thema der verbotspartei die
Grünen würden sie das unterschreiben
kann man das so sagen dass die grün sie
verbieten wollen so viel regulieren
wollen wie Herr Dorndorf ist
angesprochen hat also ich würde es ein
bisschen weiter ziehen tatsächlich also
ich glaube die Grünen sind so eine Art
Avantgarde eines bestimmten Zeitgeistes
und der ist in der Tat also etwas
paternalistisch und ja auf eine
eigenartige Weise obrigkeitsstaatlich
also ich finde die Ansprache der Bürger
hat sich sehr geändert ich beobachte das
besonders stark seit Corona es hat aber
möglicherweise auch schon vorher
angefangen aber also insofern es war
nicht allein ein Problem der Grünen
sondern es fing eigentlich in der
Regierungszeit von Frau Merkel an zum
Beispiel wenn ich erinnern darf also an
ein relativ unterirdische Werbekampagnen
wie meine
Disziplin ist unsere beste Medizin also
das hat eine Bundesregierung plakatiert
das tut keine Bundesregierung die also
sozusagen in in ihren Staatsbürgern
Erwachsene mündige Menschen sieht
sondern das ist im Grunde genau so ein
Schritt in diese Richtung also
Infantilisierung des Bürgers und ein
sehr herablassendes patternalistisches
Verhältnis das setzt sich jetzt fort
also mit großen Kampagnen ja auch aus
dem aus dem Hause Habeck zum
Energiesparen und aus dem Hause
Lauterbach mal wieder zum Impfen und
jeweils eigentlich also natürlich gibt
es da dann irgendwo noch Fakten Blöcke
in den Begleitmaterialien und so weiter
aber die Kampagnen sind eigentlich rein
werblich und rein moralisch und das ist
glaube ich derzeitgeist den die Grünen
besser als alle anderen verkörpern das
moralisieren von Diskussionen also nicht
zu sagen ich finde dein Argument falsch
und zwar aus folgenden Gründen und kann
dir vielleicht die Zahlen nennen und
überdenkt das doch noch mal sondern du
bist ein böser Mensch wenn du diese
Meinung vertrittst und das hat sich
leider sehr ausgebreitet und ich glaube
das macht unseren politischen Diskurs
ziemlich kaputt heller aus
moralisierende Debatten sind ihnen bei
ihren Recherchen ja glaube ich sehr sehr
oft begegnet vor allem während ihrer
corona-recherche natürlich also wenn wir
über die Grünen sprechen dann hat der
Dorendorf ja eben deutlich gesagt dass
die Grünen das Fleisch essen und so
weiter verbieten und ich habe so ein
bisschen immer den Eindruck dass man den
Grünen irgendwie nachsagt so die ganzen
Dinge die jetzt vielleicht mal
angegangen werden müssen dass die das
kreiert haben und da kann ich nur sagen
ich habe das vorhin gehört mittlerweile
frei ist for future demonstriert er
sogar gegen die Grünen also man darf
jetzt nicht sagen nur weil da eine grüne
Farbe ist dass die immer alles irgendwie
in diese Richtung Natur nachhaltig und
sonst was ganz im Gegenteil es gibt ganz
viele Fleischesser bei den Grünen es
gibt ja auch Fleisch nie Supermarkt es
ist jetzt nicht so als wäre
fleischverbot in unserem Land ja genau
also aber es gibt einfach sehr viele
Fleischesser bei den Grünen also da ist
das gar kein richtiges Argument zu sagen
die Grünen würden dass die machen das
gar nicht also die verbieten vielleicht
Fleisch aber eher aus monetären Gründen
oder weil ihnen die Welt sich so gut
gefällt da habe ich ja eben schon von
mit angefangen aber ich habe ein
bisschen Expertise ich habe in den 90er
Jahren das ist ja schon für viele junge
Leute ganz weit weg habe ich mich für
die Rechte der Tiere eingesetzt und habe
da also gesehen dass das ganz
interessant ist ich war also in
Legebatterien ich habe in
massentierhaltungsbetrieben habe ich
mich umschauen dürfen und können und ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen die corona-zeit
hat mich sehr daran erinnert dass wir
das eigentlich schon haben und dass wir
im Grunde genommen in der corona-zeit
mit Lockdown mit Masken und so weiter
mit Impfung haben sie ein Pflege
Batterien erinnert nicht anlegebatterien
an die Massentierhaltung also Rinder die
quasi dicht an dich nehmen ja das ist
aber so also weil letztendlich müssen
sie ja nur nach China gucken da sehen
sie es noch mal ganz extrem da werden ja
ganze Städte abgeschlossen wegen der
corona-maßnahmen und da werden da wird
ja umgegangen wie mit ich sag das jetzt
mal mit Vieh und die werden komplett in
rechtet und damit kann man ja sehen dass
auch das Vieh also die Tiere die eine
Seele haben und ein Geist haben die
werden auch komplett entrichtet und
niemand spricht darüber und ganz ehrlich
ich war in den 90ern 95 war ich aktiv
und was haben wir heute 2022 das sind
jetzt 27 Jahre ganz ehrlich das ist eine
Katastrophe dass das nicht
weitergekommen ist okay es empfehle
Ihnen viele Leute jetzt vegan und
vegetarisch und so weiter ich finde das
gut ich esse überhaupt gar kein Fleisch
ich es einfach die Angst der Tiere nicht
damit denn die haben Angst und dann muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen das sind aber
nicht die Grünen die das nach vorne
treiben damit man moralische Aussage
weil wenn sie sagen sie essen kein
Fleisch sie essen Angst der Tiere nicht
dann sagen sie im Umkehrschluss
ich esse gerne Fleisch sehr gerne ich
finde auch die Jagd gut das heißt sie
sagen mir jetzt eigentlich im
Umkehrschluss ich esse die Angst der
Tiere das ist ja was moralisierendes was
eigentlich auch nee weil das sind ja für
physikalische Vorgänge wenn also ein
Tier zur Schlachtung geführt wird müssen
Sie immer damit rechnen dass dieses Tier
das merkt das gleich was schlimmes
passiert und das werden sie auch merken
wenn sie vor irgendwas Angst haben mir
passiert in ihren Zellen auch irgendwas
und da brauche ich gar keinen Mediziner
oder Biologe zu sein da weiß ich dass
das mit Sicherheit sich nicht gut
auswirkt da werden Sachen ausgeschüttet
im Körper die sie damit Essen und das
ist ja nicht moralisierend wir Fragen
hier doch einmal Herr Doro die These
mitgebracht hat und hier auch der
jagdexperte ist kann ich denn noch
weiter mein Rehwild essen oder esse ich
die Angst des Tieres mit und werde daran
trainieren ja das ist einfach so üben
und wir schießen so dass also wirklich
auch das Stück im Schuss das heißt das
ist ja auch wir auch in Dannenberg haben
wir ja sehr viele Muttertiere das heißt
also ich meine von von den Rindern her
das heißt die Leben auf der Wiese und
die sind nachher so wild dass man sie
nicht mehr zum Schlachter ziehen kann
sondern dann werden sie auch geschossen
und das geht ganz sanft muss ich ganz
ehrlich komisch anhört aber das was sie
sagen
wirklich so und das was sie sagen haben
sie haben vollkommen recht darum bei den
Schlachthöfen und so weiter wird das ja
eigentlich auch schon so gemacht dass
man versucht die Schweine und die Rinder
so zu transportieren und in die Räume zu
führen dass in dieser Adrenalinausstoß
weil das kann man nicht tatsächlich
messen aber Corona sah das ja genauso
aus bei der Qualität vom Impfzentrum
Schlange stehen das gleiche genau also
auf jeden Fall
nicht relativ einfach und da ist es halt
einfach rein optisch dass man dass man
da halt natürlich die Möglichkeit hat
dass das Stück nichts merkt aber es geht
ja auch um Preise ich finde bei der
fleischdebatte wird auch oft vergessen
wenn man jetzt sagt Massentierhaltung
nein das ist natürlich moralisch richtig
aber irgendwann sagt man ja dann auch
dass vielleicht Geringverdiener kein
Fleisch mehr essen können weil sie sich
nicht leisten können wäre das denn
richtig nein das ist natürlich nicht
richtig und was hast du
Massentierhaltung also ich kenne auch
viele Biobetriebe wenn sie mal sehen wie
viel tausend Schweine die haben
natürlich haben die eine andere Fläche
weil Massentierhaltung
machen viele an der Anzahl der der
Stücke fest das ist im Wald sondern es
kommt natürlich auf die Fläche an und
wir müssen natürlich auch produzieren
diese produzieren nicht nur für
Deutschland sondern auch für andere
Länder und da haben wir auch einen
entsprechenden auftragen wir haben ja
eigentlich die schärfsten Kontrollen
überhaupt in Europa das ist ja auch das
große Problem dass unsere Landwirte
haben das in anderen Ländern wie Polen
da wird das erst zehn Jahre später
umgesetzt bei uns wird es meistens immer
sofort umgesetzt und das eine großes
großes Problem und darum brauchen wir ja
natürlich auch den die konventionelle
Landwirtschaft damit wir auch die die
Leute die nicht so viel Geld haben auch
natürlich versorgen können aber es hat
sich ja unheimlich viel schon getan also
es ist ich finde es ist immer die Frage
wie erreicht man denn eine
gesellschaftliche Verbesserung also ich
glaube wir können uns wahrscheinlich
darauf einigen dass es bestimmte Arten
von Massentierhaltung gibt die wirklich
Tierquälerei sind und das möchte man
nicht unterstützen indem man das kauft
und gleichzeitig wenn man sehr wenig
Geld hatten möchte man vielleicht
trotzdem auch mal irgendwann aber oder
vielleicht essen aber es hat sich
tatsächlich ja aber das Bewusstsein hat
sich es gibt natürlich viel mehr
biologische Landwirtschaft jetzt
ökologische Landwirtschaft und ist die
Menschen versuchen ja gute Produkte zu
kaufen wir haben eine Kennzeichnung
jetzt also aus welcher Art von Haltung
kommt das ich finde man kann auch
darüber diskutieren dass man sagt möchte
ich lieber einmal gegangen das
fleischkons genau man sieht den Rückgang
des fleischlos es gibt auch leckere
Sachen jetzt also die ersatz-burger
schmecken auch viel besser jetzt aus zu
erbsenproteinen oder so als vor 20
Jahren insofern das ist doch eine eine
schöne evolutionäre also eine
vernünftige Entwicklung zum besseren
aber das kann man doch mit Argumenten
tun und Diskussionen und eben nicht mit
der mit der Vorschrift also ich möchte
eigentlich lieber dass Menschen in einer
Demokratie sich frei entscheiden können
zu solchen Dingen und nicht darüber kann
man hart streiten aber man muss also
nicht den Veggie verordnen
die Grünen ja auch nicht geschafft ihn
zu verorten nein und es hat ihnen sehr
geschadet übrigens also sozusagen dafür
haben sie aber der Wahl dann direkt die
Quittung gekriegt bei der damaligen hier
wird geschmunzelt links sehe ich ja ich
bin weder Politiker noch mache ich mir
da bisher in großparteiprogramm
irgendwelche Gedanken zu aber ich habe
es anders mitbekommen und es ging es ums
Massentierhaltung und vernünftige
Herstellung von Nahrungsmitteln da war
nicht nur Fleisch mit gemeint ja das
heißt wir haben eigentlich ein Problem
wie wir unsere Nahrungsmittel
produzieren vor allen Dingen wie viel
wir davon wegwerfen oder nicht als zum
Essen gebrauchen ja da müssen wir uns
umstellen und ich hatte es auch von den
Grünen nicht anders wahrgenommen dass es
da ein Punkt ist dass es zugespitzt wird
dass mir kein Fleisch mehr essen sollen
finde ich dann übertrieben ich esse auch
gerne Fleisch ich esse vor allen Dingen
gerne lecker ich esse eben auch neu
entdeckte legen Gerichte wenn sie gut
schmecken ja und vor allen Dingen wenig
Chemie in beinhalten sondern im
Nahrungsmittel die man auch zum Essen
gemacht hat und nicht irgendwelche
künstlicher Form irgendwas nachbaut also
ich bin auf dem Bergmannstraße
gewesen da hat man versucht die
Currywurst Virgin nachzubauen ja das war
eine chemiewurst ja die mag so ähnlich
geschmeckt haben aber ich würde sie
allein deswegen nicht kaufen weil dann
eben an die normale Wurst gibt warum
soll ich dann die kunstwurst essen und
ich glaube nicht dass das unser
politischer Weg ist zu sagen der
verbieten irgendwas oder wir feiern
irgendwann
ja sondern wir müssen einfach neu
nachdenken wir hatten auch noch kein
Corona und wir hatten auch noch keinen
Ukraine gekrieg ja als wir die
Diskussion vorgeführt haben deswegen
müssen uns glaube ich an unseren in
unserem Leben an das Anpassen was wir
gerade geboten bekommen und dass wir
Energie anders brauchen können als sie
wegzuwerfen das ist auf jeden Fall
richtig einmal noch in der Innenpolitik
und kommt Frau Gaschke und ihrer These
heute Abend in Ukraine Krieg machen wir
jetzt nicht auf aber wir bleiben bei der
Innenpolitik in ihrer These naja was
mich ja Dauer beschäftigt ist irgendwie
der Zustand dieser Ampelkoalition und da
ist sozusagen die neueste spannende
Umdrehung das jetzt also der
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
verkündet hat und zwar offensichtlich
ohne seinen liebe Kollegen Christian
Linder von der FDP auf dem
Finanzministerium auch nur zu fragen das
ist also keine Auswirkung auf den
Strompreis habe wenn die Atomkraftwerke
vom Netz gehen und das war ja nun nicht
die erste Runde in Sachen Atomkraft also
die Grünen hatten da ja auch eine
Beschlusslage und waren also es lag ihn
sehr viel daran dass man insgesamt
aussteigt also möglichst schnell es gab
einen anderslautenden Expertenrat also
verschiedene Experten haben gesagt macht
das in dieser Situation lieber nicht ihr
könnt erheblich sozusagen doch was
beitragen gegen die schlimme
Energieknappheit im Moment wenn ihr wenn
ihr die Atomkraftwerke weiterlaufen
lasst dann ging das nicht wegen des
grünen Parteitages der das nicht dulden
wollte dann hat man sich geeinigt zwei
Atomkraftwerke bis zum nächsten Frühjahr
dann brauchte es ein Machtwort des
Kanzlers nun also das dritte
Atomkraftwerk auch bis zum Frühjahr
laufen zu lassen in einer der schwersten
energiekrisen die wir je erlebt haben
und das ist natürlich sozusagen jetzt
ein Aufreger es ist aber im Grunde ja
nur ein Symptom für eine Koalition die
eigentlich überhaupt nicht zusammenpasst
was wir immer stärker merken und also
unsere Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger
merken es auch also die zwei Drittel
finden sind sind sehr unzufrieden mit
der Arbeit der Ampelkoalition und drei
Viertel machen sich große unsere oder
sogar sehr große Sorgen um ihre Zukunft
alles Aktuelle umfragezahlen und ich
glaube man spürt da einfach man hat hier
zwei linke Parteien die die Grünen und
die SPD die im Grunde also mit großen
steuerfinanzierten Ausgabenprogramm nach
Problemen werfen und zwar nach jedem
Problem mit einem weiteren Programm und
eine FDP die eigentlich von ihrer
Grundausrichtung her das Schulden machen
das inflationstreibende Schulden machen
die milliardenprogramme eher kritisch
sehen muss und einen Christian Linder
der das also mühsam noch ausbalanciert
bekommt als Finanzminister ob er das
auch zum Teil natürlich mit
Schattenhaushalten und Sondervermögen ob
er das im nächsten Jahr mit der
Schuldenbremse die immer in der
Verfassung steht noch hinbekommt ist die
Frage also da sind so viele
Sollbruchstellen drin in dieser
Koalition dass man und ich glaube die
die Wähler spüren das klar wir haben das
jetzt alle irgendwie so zusammenge aber
es funktioniert nicht gut aber es stimmt
es stimmt dass die Bürger das das spüren
auch ein Umfragen Herr Scholz seid ihr
jetzt auch keine Grenzen
aber man fragt sich ja dann doch als
Bürger ich frage mich das immer wieder
warum bleiben die denn dann jetzt die
ganze Zeit zusammen also wären neue
Wahlen eine Option würde es Deutschland
dann besser gehen das ist eben die große
Frage und ich glaube die FDP sozusagen
es wäre Selbstmord wenn die FDP jetzt
auf einen Koalitionsbruch hinwirken
würde und das ist unser großes Dilemma
wir kommen aus dieser
regierungssituation im Grunde kaum raus
man sieht bei der FDP jetzt schon also
die ist ja zum Teil glaube ich auch ein
bisschen gewählt worden für ihre
standhaftehaltung in der corona-frage
dann haben Sie jetzt da doch etwas weich
gespült mit Lauterbach wieder
Kompromisse gemacht sie sie schmeißen
sich sehr ran finde ich bei der
Grünen rot-grünen Gesellschaftspolitik
das ist glaube ich auch nicht das was
ihre Kernklientel aus Apothekern und
Hoteliers so super findet
folglich sind sie also jetzt schon in
Niedersachsen aus dem Landtag geflogen
in drei oder vier anderen
Landesregierungen sind Sie auch nicht
mehr drin wir erinnern uns ihnen im Bund
auch schon mal passiert nach der
Regierungszeit mit Frau Merkel zusammen
ich glaube die FDP wenn sie jetzt in
dieser Krisensituation mit Kriegsangst
energieangst und Corona immer noch nicht
ganz weg wenn Sie jetzt einen Bruch
herbeiführt und neu waren das wird ihnen
auch wieder keiner danken weil dann
kommt der eigentlich beim Bürger an die
Partei ist immer wichtiger als das Land
und da ist für die FDP das aus wäre
werden die sowieso in der Regierung
bleiben ja aber auf der anderen Seite
finde ich muss man ist auch politisch
bewerten also das kann man hier
verstehen also dass die jetzt eine
Sorten und man muss vielleicht
fairerweise auch sagen also eine
Regierungskrise jetzt ein Wahlkampf in
dieser Situation
also davor kann man auch Angst haben
also man kann vielleicht vor dieser
Regierung etwas Angst haben aber man
kann sozusagen vor der neuwahlsituation
auch Angst haben und es ist ja ein
bisschen auch ein Problem der
alternativen also Friedrich Merz wird ja
in Umfragen also noch schlechter und
noch weniger fähig in die Probleme zu
lösen eingeschätzt als Olaf Scholz und
der ist schon so unbeliebt also die
Union schafft es offensichtlich nicht
sich als eine starke Alternative sehr
fragen wir doch mal direkt bei Herr
dohrendorf sprach ihr Parteivorsitzender
Friedrich Merz ist das ein guter Typ
okay so also da wäre Deutschland richtig
weit vorne
das was hier gerade gesagt worden ist
dass man eventuellen Bruch hat das
können Sie völlig vergessen weil diese
Politiker an ihren Amt kleben an ihre
Macht und an ihren schwarzen Wagen und
so lange das da ist glauben Sie nicht
dass die sich in einer Legislaturperiode
trennen auf keinen Fall also diese
können sagen nein eh schon den schwarzen
Wagen wegnehmen ja das ist ja eine
andere Geschichte ich habe den
Landwirten gesagt als sie hier
demonstriert haben ihr müsst eine Woche
das Ding geht dicht machen dass diese
schwarzen Autos nicht mehr fahren können
dann bewirkt er etwas
egal aber wenn sie dann mit der U-Bahn
oder S-Bahn fahren
nein aber wenn man was bewirken will
hier dann muss man das halt so machen
bei ankleben stört bitte aber ankleben
stört auch eine Woche Traktoren wer kein
Problem ja
genau
war Gegner der Frauenquote ja wir haben
jetzt so ein so ein ich sag jetzt mal
eine Geschichte nächstes Jahr 30 %. dann
40% 50 % und gucken uns zwei Jahre an
und dann schauen wir ob sich das ob das
etwas bewirkt hat oder nicht ich war
gegen die Frauenquote weil ich genug
Frauen kennen die wirklich richtig gut
sind und die junge Frauen in der CDU
waren auch dagegen ja
erst einmal die Partei wieder geeint das
muss man einfach mal sagen ja hat hat
viel ausgewechselt hat neue Ideen
reingebracht wir sind ja gerade dabei
das ein bisschen umzusetzen dann müssen
uns auch ein bisschen Zeit lassen wir
müssen es auch
Zeit ja vier Jahre und wir werden auch
die Opposition richtig annehmen und wenn
sie mal die die Debatten im Parlament
sehen dann waren die vom März gegenüber
Scholz und den ganzen Themen wirklich
sehr gut das muss ich einfach so sagen
wenn er dann halt bei den Umfrage
Geschichten nicht richtig wahrgenommen
wird dann gehe ich auch mal ein bisschen
auf die Presse rein ja das wissen wir ja
auch aber finden Sie denn dass die Union
genug Druck macht also kommt da genug
aus der Opposition
Ansätze
Opposition das war ja vorher auch so bei
den Grünen die haben auch keine
Lösungsansätze gebracht die haben immer
erstmal versucht den Finger in die Wunde
zu stecken das ist ja nun natürlich auch
mit regiert ja das war eher das Problem
aber
halt nur in diesem Land ist so nicht
Friedrich Merz nein das habe ich nicht
den Eindruck sie hat sehr gute Thesen ja
ich habe geschmunzelt und Frau
Wagenknecht hätte ich auch nie gedacht
hat mir hat ein paar Sätze gesagt die
fand ich völlig richtig und das ist ja
auch okay wir haben sich heute als
wagenknecht-fan nein das würde ich nicht
machen ich bin in ein Friedrich Merz Fan
das muss ich einfach sagen weil er
glaube ich auch ein bisschen Zeit
braucht um die die Schritte die ihr
jetzt die wir auch brauchen in der
Bundespolitik in der Bundes CDU jetzt
auch richtig umzusetzen
also auf mich wirkt er das orientiert
einerseits macht man diesen diesen
diesen diesen
pseudo fortschrittlichen Kram wie die
Frauenquote mit da hätte man doch
einfach sagen können das haben noch
andere Parteien nun lange genug
ausprobiert die sind nicht auch nicht
erfolgreicher damit also wir sind die
Partei die die 16 Jahre lang der
Kanzlerin gestellt hat ganz ohne Quote
wir versuchen es mal auf einem anderen
Weg es ist ja keiner gegen
Frauenförderung ist ja nur die Frage ob
die Quote intelligentes Instrument ist
allein dann schmeißt er sich ran bei
irgendwelchen also vermeintliche
rechterin oder konservativeren Wählern
die er kriegen müsste um wieder
erfolgreich zu sein indem man sowas
unverantwortliches aus meiner Sicht sagt
also sozialtourismus nun ausgerechnet
bei Flüchtlingen aus der Ukraine das
finde ich perfide und das nämlich
zurückgerufen
und teilweise bei die richtigen Fragen
hat er das ja gesagt er ist dann
zurückgeholt hat sich dafür auch
entschuldigt ja und dann frage ich mich
wo ist da das Koordinatensystem ich
glaube wo wir eine echte
repräsentationslücke haben ist
tatsächlich im bürgerlich konservativen
Bereich also die Leute denen diese ganze
Identitätspolitik und der ganze
verbotskram auf die Nerven gehen das
könnte ja das Gendern das könnte die
Union sein aber aber märz präsentiert
das noch nicht richtig und das Problem
ist natürlich die AFD hat sozusagen
Platz rechts von der CDU weggenommen und
Platz für eine Neugründung weggenommen
also da kriegt man jetzt nicht so leicht
noch irgendwas dazwischen aber man hat
die repräsentationslücke und die ganzen
Wähler gehen doch einfach erstmal in die
nicht Wahl in Niedersachsen haben sie
45% glaube ich sehe ich das auch Leute
oder was NRW waren 45% nicht wieder
Niedersachsen war auch nicht viel besser
und da ist die Frage wo kommen die
hinterher wieder raus das ist echt
gefährlich für das politische
intern war das eh mein Thema diese
schaufensterpolitik die in vielen
Bereichen Enttäuschung war müssen sie
doch klar wir haben uns mehr erwartet
ganz klar und aber das ist eben so das
sind halt dass das passiert dann halt so
und dann verlieren wir und wir müssen
jetzt halt wir haben ja nun auch völlig
alles umgekrempelt wir sind gerade dabei
wir haben neuen Fraktionsvorsitzenden
wir sind gerade dabei die Ausschüsse zu
gründen wir versuchen
nicht ganz unwichtig ne das haben wir
gerade haben sie ja gerade eben beim
März gesagt und ich glaube es ist auf
dem guten Weg wir müssen nur das Problem
ist halt immer wenn man immer erstmal
den Umfragen fragt und schaut kommt das
gut an dann ist es einfach falsch das
ist diese diese schaufensterpolitik
diese Mainstream Politik die ich nicht
mag und da hätten wir uns viel eher auch
bei Merkel schon Absenden müssen das
haben wir nie gemacht
so in die Mitte gegangen dass wir dass
wir unsere Leute eigentlich nicht im
konservativen einfach verloren haben
aber sie kommen ja nicht weiter ne also
sie haben nein ich folge ja nur an
irgendeineren Kompass und dann sind sie
halt nicht der den man will sondern man
möchte halt dann Leder leider Gottes
gemacht super du bist ein ganz toller ja
und das bin ich eben nicht sondern man
muss heute auch ganz klar wenn man kein
ja sage ist hat man es in der deutschen
Politik schwer nimmt schwierig ja das
ist auf jeden Fall für
Landesvorsitzender des Ausschusses
Internet und Medien bei der FDP in
Hamburg und ich habe mich kritisch
geäußert gegenüber dem NDR und kurze
Zeit später hat Katja Suding meinen
Ausschuss gestrichen und mit dem
Innenausschuss zusammengelegt und hat
mich dann drei Wochen später Anrufer
gesagt haben es tut mir leid wir haben
vergessen dir das zu sagen aber du
kannst zum Innenausschuss gehen da ist
jetzt deinen Ausschuss verortet welche
Gründe auch immer das gehabt haben mag
so funktioniert das bei ihnen kam ganz
klar an wer Missstände anspricht fliegt
raus
würde ich in diesem Fall tatsächlich
sagen es war 2013/14 in der Zeit und das
jetzt ein bisschen her aber die Zeit
vergeht ja sehr schnell und ich kann das
nur so erinnern ich habe viele Sachen in
der Kreis- und Landespolitik gesehen wo
ich sage damit möchte ich eigentlich
nichts mehr zu tun haben da komme ich
auch zu meinem Punkt denn wir reden ja
eigentlich über die Energiekrise und
über ich glaube die Atomkraftwerke die
an aus an aus und so weiter über diese
Frage und was mich am meisten stört
daran an genau dieser Sachen dass dieses
Wort Energie Krise so auftaucht und eine
Krise ist für mich ein Zustand der quasi
schicksalhaft über einen hinein
hereinbricht und ganz ehrlich ich glaube
diese Sache dass wir wenig also wenn
Energiemangel haben die ist ja kein
Schicksalsschlag des Universums sondern
ich würde eher sagen da hat jemand
gesagt wir wollen keine Energie mehr aus
Russland haben und welche Gründe auch
immer dafür vorherrschen man kann dann
aber die nachfolgenden Zustände nicht
Energiekrise nennen Energie an ja wer
auch immer den zugedreht hat man hat
zunächst gesagt man will diese Energie
nicht mehr haben das hat ja Frau wie
heißt sie noch Frau bärbock hat das
gesagt ich bin nicht so in der Politik
ich beobachte die ich weiß wie sie alle
aussehen und so weiter aber die hat ja
nun ganz klar gesagt wir wollen diese
Energie auch für immer nicht mehr haben
und da kann ich nur sagen wenn der
energiehahn zu ist und man sagt dann ist
es eine Krise dann hat man vorher ja
irgendwie keine Alternativen gehabt das
heißt also die mangelage ist jetzt
erstmal da zum Beispiel Energie Krieg
genannt indem wir uns befinden ja wenn
wie gesagt ich kann immer nur sagen wenn
man nach irgendwohin ruft und sagt ich
will das nicht mehr haben und dann auf
einmal hat man es nicht mehr egal ob da
jemand zugedreht hat und man hat sie ja
vorher gesagt und dann gibt es keinen
Krieg sondern dann hat man das ist die
Kinderwelt von der aber man hat sich ja
auch willentlich und wissentlich
abhängig gemacht von Russland also und
von von russischen Energielieferung und
ist gleichzeitig aber das ist ja eine
sehr schnell aber keine Krise es ist ja
eine aktive Entscheidung also das
verstehe ich sozusagen was Sie damit
sagen
ich weiß ja wie Menschen haben ja ein
feines Gespür für viele Dinge das merke
ich ja auch mit meiner Arbeit die ich
Sachen Corona mache aber ich merke das
natürlich auch bei der Frage der
Energiekrise es ist keine Krise sondern
es ist ein politischer Wille der jetzt
umgesetzt wird egal von welcher Seite
der kommt aber es gibt keinen Mangel der
das ist ja nicht so dass auf der Welt
ein Mangel an Energie herrscht sondern
die Energie die wir vorher hatten welche
Umstände auch immer dazu geführt haben
dass das jetzt die benutzen wir jetzt
nicht mehr und dadurch haben wir
wahrscheinlich eine mangelage noch haben
sie nicht vielleicht wird sie auch nur
vorgezeigt vielleicht klappt das ja auch
alles man weiß es nicht es ist ja
vielleicht auch gar nicht schlecht man
weiß es ja nicht was dabei am Ende
rauskommt aber es ist so eine Welt die
nicht ausprobiert ist und wo jetzt
meines Erachtens ganz gut passt das eine
kindliche Welt sich dann auch existiert
die sagt ja wir gucken mal was passiert
das ob man das mit Hunderten von
Millionen Menschen so machen kann weiß
ich nicht das ist ein großes Experiment
auch da wieder und deswegen sage ich
kindliche Weltsicht ist gefragt die
Leute mögen das nicht und im Winter wenn
es kalt wird werden die möglicherweise
auf der Straße auftauchen dann werden
Sie nicht nur wegen Corona auftauchen da
waren ja auch schon 100.000 auf der
Straße sondern dann werden Sie
vielleicht auch wegen der mangelage an
Energie auftauchen nicht nur die
mangelage der Energie interessiert uns
auch unsere Zuschauer sondern auch die
corona-pandemien wie es da jetzt
weitergeht und da kommen wir gleich zu
nach einer ganz kurz Unterbrechung bis
gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig realitätsfähig
wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren ganz richtig was die
Frau Wagner Ich sag ehrlich gesagt ist
das fast totalitär was sie davon
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glückler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst das Problem ist nicht
dass wir zu wenig Stadt haben wir haben
zu viel Staaten wenn die alle wegfallen
und wir uns gegenseitig in Berlin mit
der Cappuccinos verkaufen das
funktioniert nicht dann ist mit
Wohlstand aber das ist alles Essig als
freiheitsliebender Mensch würde ich
sagen das muss jedem erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und um Währungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch
was machbar ich finde aber diese gesamte
Debatte die wir auch führen auch ein
bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt mit dem wir reden
[Musik]
wir sind zurück bei 8:15 Uhr wir machen
jetzt direkt weiter mit dr Peter Welling
und ich bin sehr gespannt weil ich
glaube es ist keine these sondern eher
ein Aufruf ich bin gespannt wie sie es
formulieren heute Abend ja vielen Dank
für die Möglichkeiten dass du sagen ich
bin ja jemand der jeden Tag mit Corona
umgehen muss sowohl mit Patienten die
Corona haben als auch mit Leuten die
geimpft werden wollen
ich finde diese Diskussion die wir im
Moment die ganze Zeit führen schwierig
weil wir eigentlich die medizinischen
Grundlagen verlassen haben jede
medikamentenzulassung hat in Deutschland
zu recht gutes Recht ja und wir brauchen
dafür auch Zeit und Daten ja und
deswegen es war für mich so diese Frage
wann kriegen wir den Impfstoff müssen
wir jetzt haben und
was passiert dann wenn er da ist jetzt
ist er da jetzt ist er angepasst wir
haben genügend Impfstoff das sind ja
alles Änderungen die eingetreten sind
und wir haben jetzt eigentlich nur die
Aufgabe alle die die geimpft werden
wollen zu impfen und müssen also nicht
eigentlich um die kümmern die vielleicht
20 Prozent oder so weiter die nicht
geimpft werden wollen und das ist ja
ganz gutes Recht dass sie selber zu
entscheiden nur ist es auch kein Recht
durch eine nichtimpfung andere Leute
anzustecken ja und das ist mein
tägliches Praxisproblem wir haben keine
getrennten Räume wir können keine
infektierten Patienten Trennen von
anderen und wir haben frisch operiert
wir haben Tumorpatienten im Wartezimmer
und die erwarten meiner Meinung nach
zurecht dass wir dafür sorgen dass kein
akuter corona-fall in der Praxis die
anderen anstecken kann fremdschutz oder
also ich bin also wenn man geimpft ist
dann kann man doch trotzdem also andere
anstecken jeder Impfung so aber immerhin
ist es ja so dass die geimpften selber
schwere selten schwere erkranken ja das
ist der einzelne Ausnahmefälle gibt
weiß ich nicht wenn er nicht krank wird
schon
die Frage ist doch ich muss doch nicht
sagen weil jemand mit Corona im Raum ist
wird der Tuma Patient krank da muss ich
ja noch anstecken da gibt es nur Masken
zwischen da gibt es Abstandsregeln und
so weiter nur ich finde diese ganz
Diskussion dass wir mit Corona dauerhaft
umgehen müssen sollten wir einfach mal
zur Kenntnis nehmen und da sagen früher
war alles besser selbst die Zukunft das
ist nicht der Punkt wir müssen damit
lernen umzugehen und nicht sie haben
mich als corona-experten beschrieben ich
würde mich als jeden Tag neu lernen in
der bezeichnen weil es ist halt eine
neue Infektionskrankheit und wie wir
damit umgehen müssen auch wir lernen und
dass wir Impfstoff haben dass wir da
Möglichkeiten haben und vor allen Dingen
so schnell ist ja auch wieder Diskussion
waren wir nicht zu schnell nein wir
waren nicht zu schnell wir haben alle
Schritte gemacht nur mal schneller als
es bisher der Fall war deswegen ich
bleibe dabei dass man Diskussionen dann
führen sollte wenn man Daten hat über
die man reden kann und über die man sich
austauschen kann und nicht die Gerüchte
aufbringt und dann Zugang an die
Gerüchte könnten ja wahr sein wir
erzählen die schon mal daher stehen es
noch
eine eine Frage zur Kommunikation hat
Herr Lauterbach nicht genau das getan er
hat gesagt die Impfung ist
nebenwirkungsfrei war sie dann nicht er
hat gesagt die Impfung bietet
fremdschutz hat sie denn nicht also
nicht genau das in der Kommunikation
passiert ich fand das gerade so
angenehmer als sie gesagt haben ich
möchte gar nicht als corona-experte
bezeichnet werden ich bin lernen darf
wir müssen dazu lernen aber genau das
hat die Politik doch nie vermittelt man
hatte doch das Gefühl die wissen alles
oder nicht weiß ich nicht ob Herr
Lauterbach immer richtig zitiert worden
ist oder ob man nur das ausgeschrieben
hat was man dann genau wissen wollte ich
kenne Herr Lauterbach von einigen
Diskussionen im tsvg da war er noch
nicht Gesundheitsminister ich weiß dass
er eigentlich sehr fundiert diskutieren
kann wenn man ihn lässt und wenn er
nicht zum Beispiel in der Rolle ist aber
die ganze Diskussion zu führen bevor Sie
fundiert mit Fakten da ist auch welchen
Uni-Shop wenn lässt man wie zu was muss
da drin sein wie muss der aussehen und
so weiter
das hätte man im stillen Kämmerlein wir
haben eine Deko und ständige
Impfkommission die halt sagen kann wann
was wie zugelassen wird und die
stickomitglieder sind Ehrenamtler die
eigentlich aller nebenbei noch arbeiten
dass die der sich die heftigste Mühe
gegeben haben dass so schnell wie
möglich zu machen mit zweifel ich nicht
aber ich bin ja auch gewohnt damit
umzugehen alle anderen Impfungen sind
auch über die Deko gelaufen die
Impfempfehlungen habe ich wir hören mal
einmal rein was Herr Lauterbach heute
gerade heute gesagt hat auch zum Thema
Impfen ist ja immer besser als über ihn
zu reden er sagt ja genug in der
Öffentlichkeit hören wir mal rein
es ist leider nicht so dass die Pandemie
vorbei ist sondern wir erleben derzeit
allenfalls eine Atempause wir sind auch
gewahrt dass wir damit rechnen müssen
dass andere Varianten uns in den
nächsten Monaten noch vor
Herausforderungen stellen werden wir
wissen derzeit noch nicht genau
beobachtende Studienlage aber sehr
präzise wie gut unsere vivalenten
Impfstoffe mit denen wir derzeit die
boosterimpfungen vornehmen wirken werden
das können wir noch nicht genau sagen
da habe ich mir die Frage ganz klar
gestellt erhöht das die Glaubwürdigkeit
daran sich impfen zu lassen wenn hier
hat er Lauterbacher eigentlich selbst
seine nicht Zweifel aber er hat ja
gesagt wir wissen es noch nicht so genau
wäre es dann nicht fast ehrlicher zu
sagen wir wissen auch noch nicht ob sie
wirken
nein wir haben ja gerade diese
Impfstoffe gefordert um uns an die
aktuellen Varianten anzupassen die er
wirklich vom Zusammenbau anders sind als
die bisherigen und dass die bisherigen
nicht so gut vorangekommen egal jetzt in
welche Variante schützen wissen wir wir
haben danach gerufen und haben gesagt
wir brauchen einen angepassten Impfstoff
den haben wir jetzt und natürlich ist
bei jedem Impfstoff die Sache die gut er
schützt weiß man erst nachdem er geimpft
worden ist und ich vorher und die Daten
brauchen wir halt durch die geimpften
weil wir gefährden sie ja nicht wir
haben eine Zulassungsverfahren gemacht
in jeglicher Form und wir gehen da
verschiedene
gleich vom Stuhl ich muss da dringend
mal was zu sagen also es ist ja wirklich
es ist ja wirklich sie sind ja Herr Dr
Welling sie sind ja wirklich durch
verschiedene Bereiche gerannt ich will
das mal rückwärts wieder aufrollen also
die Zulassung gibt ja keinen Freibrief
dafür dass es nicht am Ende
Nebenwirkungen gibt also ich war jetzt
zum Beispiel im Bundesverwaltungsgericht
beim Prozess der Duldungspflicht der
Soldaten in Leipzig dabei
Oberst Arzt Prof dr Kehl der
Berichterstatter für des
Bundesverteidigungsministerium und er
hat ganz klar gesagt ein Soldaten haben
wir verloren wegen der Impfung so der
ist durch die Impfung gestorben Punkt
das ist eine amtliche Information die
ist vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht
ausgesprochen der ist gestorben dann
haben wir mindestens 54 schwerst und
schwerwiegende Nebenwirkungen gehabt bei
den Soldaten bei den deutschen Soldaten
nachdem aber die Bundeswehr auf Ihre
Internetseite immer noch sagt vertragen
alle so wie sie das gesagt haben es ist
nicht so und die 54 schwerst und alle
Impfungen das Hervorbringen er hat nicht
gesagt wir haben schon über kovic gerade
gesprochen und dann haben Sie jetzt Wahl
angebracht
aber ich will trotzdem ich will das
trotzdem mal fortführen weil da sind so
viele Sachen die sie sagen die ich von
Ärzten höre die sich gar nicht mit den
Zahlen auseinandersetzen die behaupten
das einfach und ich glaube das hängt
auch an der 500 Millionen Euro Kampagne
von der Bundesregierung die tatsächlich
500 Millionen Euro in die sogenannte
aufklärungskamp hier gesteckt hat die
Frage steht jetzt wenn man aufklärt dann
gehört ja auch dazu über die Risiken
aufzuklären also bezeichne ich das als
Werbekampagne und so wird es auch
teilweise ja gesagt Impfkampagne wird ja
nicht gesagt Aufklärung Werbung ich muss
doch meine Leute auch darüber aufklären
dass das gewisse Risiken gibt und sie
tun ja gerade so als wäre das
nebenwirkungsfrei aber das ist wir
führen jetzt gerade keine impfgespräche
wir führen das weil sie gesagt haben in
der Klinik wäre ein fremdschutz gegeben
denn dann sind sie davon abgerückt das
hat er Lauterbach auch gemacht ich bin
nicht von der Klinik ich habe noch nie
haben gesagt sie sind in der Klinik und
da müssen sie auch aufpassen dass die
Leute sich nicht anstecken und dafür
müssen sie geimpft sein ich bin in der
Praxis
in denen und da müssen die Leute geimpft
sein damit sie sozusagen nicht und dann
hat habe gesagt dass der Patienten die
da sitzen nicht angesteckt werden wollen
das habe ich gesagt aber die werden ja
durch die geimpften eingesteckt unter
anderem genau
Patienten es ist so es gibt ja zahlen
und wir sehen ja dass die es gibt ja
Gruppen die sind stark durchgeimpft das
sind ja gerade Klinik und
Krankenhauspersonal man hat ja von denen
verlangt dass sie sich impfen lassen und
man hat ja erhofft dass es dann und
dadurch zu wenige Ansteckung kommt wir
haben zum Beispiel das nicht so gewesen
nee das ist nicht so gewisses kannst du
mehr Ansteckungen gemerkt durch die
Impfung ja okay es ist so dass die
Uniklinikum Eppendorf zum Beispiel die
haben auf Ihre Internetseite
wunderschönen Verlauf da können Sie
wunderbar sehen dass sie dort eine bei
einer Klinik mit 14.400 Beschäftigten
dass sie eine Inzidenz dort errechnen
können können sie sich teilweise bis zu
1.400 Beschäftigte gehabt die wegen
Corona ausgefallen sind und die Inzidenz
derer ist deutlich überhöht seit Ende
März 2022 gegenüber der Vergleichsgruppe
in Hamburg jetzt denkt man okay ist
vielleicht ein Klinikum ist vielleicht
stimmt irgendwas nicht und man kann es
vielleicht nicht vergleichen bei der
Bundeswehr ist das genauso bei der
Bundes dann haben wir 183.000
Soldatinnen und Soldaten und die sind ja
durch die Duldungspflicht auch
verpflichtet gewesen haben eine
Impfquote von bis zu 97 Prozent und dort
haben wir eine Ansteckungsrate die liegt
deutlich über der Vergleichsgruppe der
15 bis 59-Jährige aber wir haben gegen
den altes Virus geimpft und wir haben
Momenten neue Erkrankungsfälle zumindest
seit diesem Jahr welche Zahlen nehmen
sie denn jetzt gerade wir können ja
Wirklichkeit also Sie haben ja das
Problem dass sie immer mit Studien
arbeiten und dass sie immer sagen ich
arbeite mit Patienten ja gut aber sie
haben nur wenige Patienten sie haben
vielleicht im Quartal 1000 Patienten
oder so und das ist natürlich stimmt so
nicht ich habe bis zu drei im Fallen
betreut und habe 5000 Leute pro Tag
geimpft
alleine aber ist ja kein Beurteiler
eines krankheits-
bevor wir hier eine Studie und
zahlenschlacht machen kommen wir zu
ihrer These sonst rennt die Zeit weg sie
es passt ja sehr sehr gut weil sie
fordern ja heute was was die ich finde
das Wort ungeimpft so beschissen
deswegen was die Menschen die sich gegen
eine corona-impfung entschieden haben da
wollen sie ja heute drüber reden über
die einrichtungsbezogene Flächen das ist
tatsächlich so ich dachte tatsächlich
das mal erwähnen in Hamburg sind 250
Betretungsverbote ausgesprochen worden
zum Gesundheitspersonal in den Kliniken
und in den Pflegeheimen und ich muss
Ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen nachdem ich die
Zahlen untersucht habe zur Bundeswehr
zum Uniklinikum Würzburg zur Unikliniken
in Eppendorf in Hamburg eines der großen
Unikliniken eine der großen Unikliniken
muss ich leider feststellen dass eine
Behauptung es würde dadurch den
Patienten weniger Risiko
entgegengebracht wenn nur noch geimpfte
an sie herankommen das ist komplett
falsch und sogar es ist sogar das
Gegenteil der Fall also wir stellen
aufgrund der Daten und Zahlen fest Zeit
die dritte Impfung gegeben wird wir
tatsächlich eine erhöhte Inzidenz bei
den Geimpften vorfinden also bei starken
Gruppen die jetzt geschlossen sind
Uniklinikum Eppendorf 99% Impfquote
Bundeswehr bis zu 97 Uniklinikum
Würzburg auch weit über die 90 Prozent
und alle Gruppen die weniger geimpft
sind sind tatsächlich weniger von Corona
betroffen wir sehen das in den
Intensivstationen wir haben nur nach
11,4 Prozent da sind die umgeimpften
ungeimpfte und wir stellen fest dass
sogar vierfach geimpfte tatsächlich auf
den Intensivstationen liegen und jetzt
kommt noch der schlimmste Teil wir haben
jetzt schon das erste Bundesland das ist
leider Herr dohrendorf ihr Bundesland
Niedersachsen wo wir mehr 80-Jährige die
an- und mit Corona gestorben sind
gegenüber 2021 und 2020 also die Impfung
wird unsere uns nicht aus der ganzen
Lage raus katapultieren aber die
Betretungsverbote sind natürlich eine
personalverengende Maßnahme die die
Kliniken in noch mehr Schwierigkeiten
bringt jeder wird gebraucht da fallen
die Leute aus in den klicken ohne Ende
und trotzdem müssen ja die und trotzdem
werden Leute nach Hause geschickt das
ist ein unmöglicher Zustand die Leute
kriegen gar keinen Ausgleich die
entlassen werden die werden bedroht mit
schreiben sie müssen sich impfen lassen
und so weiter also ein unhaltbarer
Zustand und das gleiche ist übrigens bei
der Bundeswehr und wenn wir sehen dass
die Impfung gar nichts bringt auch nicht
so aufrecht Erhaltung der Truppe dann
kann ich Ihnen nur sagen wenn sie solche
Daten nicht ansehen dann gehören sie
auch nicht in irgendwelche Expertenteams
hinein das tut mir leid dass ich ihnen
das so sagen muss sie müssen sich die
Daten angucken entschuldigung ich wusste
nicht dass ich heute hier im
Expertenteam sitze
hier eine eine
Frage die mich wirklich beschäftigt wenn
man ihrer Tiere zuhört dann sagen sie ja
eigentlich unterbrechen Sie mich gerne
wenn ich sie falsch wieder gebe dann
sagen Sie eigentlich dass schwere
Verläufe durch die Impfung nicht
verhindert werden können weil das ist ja
das Argument für die Impfung ganz klar
deswegen sich viele Menschen impfen über
60 über 70 über 80 auch Menschen mit
Vorerkrankungen würden sie also die
Impfung schon differenziert sehen oder
sagen Sie ganz klar keine corona-impfung
also ich sage ganz klar keine
corona-impfung und ich sage auch es gibt
natürlich eine zweite Möglichkeit wie
das alles zu interpretieren ist wir
sammeln ja seit drei Jahren und man muss
ja sagen wir brauchen keine Studien mehr
wir haben die Wirklichkeit als zahlen da
ich habe krankenkassendaten untersucht
ich kann ganz viele Sachen über die
Impfnebenwirkungen sagen ich kann über
die Zustände gehen nicht beweisen dass
der schwere Verlauf nicht durch die
Corona von verhindert wird die Zahlen
des RKI anzuschauen und dann sehen sie
dass die Leute die jetzt mit Corona
positivtest dass da komme ich jetzt
gleich zu dass die Leute die dort liegen
zu einem kleineren Teil als proportional
geimpft wurde
ungeimpft in den Kliniken in den
Intensivstationen liegen während die
geimpften zu einem größeren Teil dort
liegen jetzt komme ich zu dem wichtigen
Teil
auch viel mehr Menschen nicht also
geimpft als nicht geimpft das haben wir
alles dazu einberechnet und wenn Sie das
in Proportion zueinander setzen dann
sind die ungeimpften
unterproportional repräsentiert in den
Intensivstationen und deswegen können
sie davon ausgehen und wir haben auch
noch übrigens noch nie so viele über
80-jährige mit Corona in den
Krankenhäusern gehabt wie jetzt in den
letzten Wochen also in den gesamten
weltweit ansteckender also
zahlen können sie ja gar nicht sagen
aber ich weiß von die Intensivstationen
von den Kollegen die da arbeiten ja sie
kostet natürlich ein paar darf ich
demnächst mal ausreden ja dass die
Patienten die da liegen
multimodapnorbide sind also mehrere
Erkrankungen haben und gerade die der
Coronavirus am meisten trifft und dass
man durch die Impfung Corona krank wird
also diese Behauptung möchte ich gerne
widerlegen weil da gibt es genügend
Zahlen zu erleben das sind doch die
Zahlen
ja dass sie das so behaupten möchte ich
gerne allen die Zahlen können sie sich
angucken das ist keine behaupten mir das
angucken kennen die Zahlen nur nicht die
sie so interpretieren wie sie gerne
sehen ich sehe normale Neuköllner Bürger
in der Praxis und die sind deutlich
weniger krank wenn sie geimpft sind als
wenn sie nicht geimpft sind und vor
allen Dingen auch wenn Sie mit dem neuen
Impfstoff der schon kombiniert ist
geimpft sind kriegen sie auch weniger
Komiker das ist das was ich sehe wir
öffnen Sie bei der Frau Gaschke was ich
jetzt ganz stark das Gefühl habe ich
weiß nicht geht haben wir vielleicht
einfach zu wenig Daten dass man einfach
jetzt ganz klar das schon sehen kann wer
jetzt hier im Recht ist oder nicht bei
diesem Battle ich glaube nicht dass wir
zu wenig Daten haben aber ich glaube
dass wir sie überhaupt nicht vernünftig
aufbereitet haben also ich glaube die
Expertenkommission zu Corona hat das ja
irgendwie versucht aber ist da an
einigen Stellen erstaunlich auch wenig
in die Tiefe gegangen und dann hat man
noch nicht auf sie gehört und dieses
hier müsste man jetzt in der Tat so
sehen dann da sind ja da kommen
natürlich zu dem was sie sagen Faktoren
dazu das ist schon richtig also wird
irgendwo mehr getestet sozusagen ist die
neuere Variante ansteckender und
deswegen so überspringt sich dann die
Übung leichter oder so also hätte ich
schon noch fragen woher kommt's nicht
was dann müsste man ja als Journalist
fragen was macht die Impfung mit dem
Körper so dass er anfälliger wird dann
wäre es natürlich komplett irre wenn es
so wäre dann muss man Journalisten
werden morgen mit ihren Fakten Prüfern
werden sie auf mich losgehen da bin ich
das bin ich ja auch schon gewohnt ich
habe ja auch schon Prozesse gegen die
Tagesschau geführt und so weiter also
all diese Sachen muss man sich ja
anhören wenn man nur die Zahlen
eigentlich nur sagt jetzt habe ich dazu
eben zu Ende sagen darf und ich finde
aber den den Umgang mit den Zahlen ganz
ganz skandalös also jetzt haben wir das
ja seit zweieinhalb Jahren seit fast
drei Jahren das Problem und ich finde so
auch sowas zu sagen also die die STIKO
ist ja ehrenamtlich und und das ist ja
sicher auch aller ehrenwert ja verdammt
noch mal warum ist die denn nach drei
Monate drei Jahren immer noch
ehrenamtlich also wenn wir jetzt ein
großes Problem haben dass die
Gesellschaft im Milliarden gekostet hat
das Kinder sozusagen ihre Jugend
gekostet hat das also demokratische
Prozesse extrem in Frage gestellt hat
dann kann ich doch wohl so eine
Kommission aufstocken dann also nicht
warum ist das RKI also immer noch nicht
in der Lage bestimmte Zahlen die
vorliegen zu interpretieren weil man
offensichtlich Interesse daran hat
Zahlen noch nicht hat also
da kommen Sie mir nicht mit Zahlen
unsere Sendezeit ist vorbei mit dem
Plädoyer von Frau Gaschke dass wir auf
jeden Fall da mehr Transparenz und mehr
zahlen benötigen oder mehr Aufklärung
benötigen morgen abends ins Tier Marcel
Reif mit mir schönen Abend noch bis
morgen tschüss machen sie es gut
[Musik]